I want to start by just sort of framing
with a discussion of political news and
aggregation so we've increasingly seen
people turn to sites like dig or reddit
or Google News where they can go and
access information from a variety of
sources that may have been socially
selected it may have been algorithm plea
selected so about fifty six percent of
adult americans who access news online
or in a typical day are going to these
news aggregators among the 18 to 29
demographic that's an even higher
percent so I want to start with a
question about sort of a general case of
one of these so imagine a web site
called news on the internets it has you
know kind of standard news aggregator
format of a title and a short abstract
and a link to the actual source and some
of these articles support your opinion
right things that you agree with and
make you feel good about what you agree
and day after day you go and it's about
the same distribution of agreeable and
disagreeable items right so each day and
that works out pretty well but then
along comes a series of news a competing
news aggregator and this one offers you
almost entirely agreeable items there
might be one or two disagreeable ones
that slip in there but day after day
after day it's a set of stories that
support your existing opinions so how
many of you think that you should prefer
that first aggregator news on the
internets okay and how many of you think
you would actually prefer a series of
news the second aggregator yeah so what
do you think most people would prefer as
their daily news aggregator right I
think most of you who says news on the
internets and who says a series of news
okay so there's been a long line of work
in this area about selective exposure
preferences particularly related to
political information where people
prefer material that supports their
opinions and they avoid challenging
information right and this is called
selective exposure theory the more
agreeable items in a list the happier
you are the more agreeable content the
better you feel right and a number of
scholars have expressed ways that this
might manifest itself online so and
being digital negroponte I talked about
a daily
me a collection of news item Tuesday
that selected based on things that have
matched your interests a bit later
sudden team comes along and says well
wait maybe this is not the best thing
for us as society or as democracy
because people may end up only engaged
with agreeable viewpoints and persuade
recently repeated this in the filter
bubble with concerns particularly about
search engine rankings and feed rankings
we're exposed to things that the system
believes will be things that you like
perhaps reducing your chance for a
serendipitous exposure to things that
you have not yet encountered when it
comes to political information seeking
online there's a variety of evidence
that supports this theory so political
bloggers predominantly link to
like-minded bloggers people's
preferences motivate their media
exposure and there's high level of
agreement in political blog comments and
so why might this be bad right so what
doesn't happen if people are only
accessing agreeable views one of those
things is deliberative discourse so the
idea is that if you're exposed to
diverse opinions and you're open to
change in your mind people become much
more public spirited citizens and that
society's reach better collective
choices at all levels of government and
that those choices have better or
greater legitimacy you aren't sitting
there concocting conspiracy theories
about how this thing you disagreed with
the past in the dead of night by an
extremely small bunch of minority people
also need to be exposed to diverse
viewpoints in order to learn right so
you have to encounter views that
challenge what you know in order to
learn things that are different than
what you do now it also can lead to
better problem-solving so more divergent
out-of-the-box thinking happens when you
have people with diverse points of view
involved and different information
available so if this is important if
there are negative consequences to
people accessing only agreeable
information what can we do about it and
so I've looked at it from kind of two
perspectives one is looking at in online
political spaces how can you better
understand what people's actual
preferences are and how those are
enacted as behavior and then ways to
encourage people to read more diverse
viewpoints if indeed there is selective
exposure behaviors occurring online and
also looking at whether there may be
other online spaces where some
serendipitous exposure to other
viewpoints is already or still happening
right so I'm going to walk through sort
of for quick pieces on this so one is
algorithms to actually select diverse
content one is ways to present diverse
content to people looking at people's
actual preferences and then one study on
this last question of whether or not
there are spaces where diverse
discussion already occurs so we'll start
with selecting diverse content and this
was using I wanted to have a system that
used just readers links votes or set of
links oh you didn't necessarily have
categories or viewpoints already it so
we'll go back to dig one of the early
examples here and there's been a lot of
at least anecdotal evidence that you
front page stories from the last seven
days would be predominantly liberal
maybe one or two conservative stories
would make it but dig was kind of having
a liberal bias and it wasn't that
everyone on dig was liberal and in fact
there were conservatives on dig but they
felt unrepresented when this happened so
they started trying to create
conservative alternatives because they
felt like they weren't heard right they
wanted a site like this but they
couldn't see their viewpoints
represented in in digs viewpoints so
they created things like lively link
Scott pub or the awkwardly named rig
right in an attempt to get that same
experience but also find viewpoints that
they agreed with it and so how can there
are ways that this can happen which I'll
talk about right where you end up with a
majority or plurality taking over an
entire front page to the exclusion of a
minority but first I want to talk about
some diversity goals so what would be an
ideal front page maybe the sidelines
algorithm which is designed to select a
more diverse set of items and then some
diversity measures and an evaluation
based on those measures so I started
with three diversity goals one is having
people feel represented so those
Republicans who are looking at digg and
saying I don't see my views here right
what's going on there is a proportional
representation of you points so you
understand maybe how widely an idea is
held and then expose everyone a
challenging viewpoints to achieve that
last learning goal where you're exposed
to things that you disagree with if you
have a really simple voting algorithm
such as approval voting or your pure
popularity each voter can vote for an
unlimited number of items up to once
each which you can do on day you can
vote
for as many stories as you want and then
you can select the K items with the most
votes the trouble is that there's this
risk of tipping in that situation if you
have a plurality or a small majority
they can sort of because they can vote
for as many sources they want and
there's a limited number of stories on
the front page they can sort of take
over the whole front page and those with
minority views don't get their stories
in there we propose an alternative
algorithm called sidelines where each
voter can vote for an unlimited number
of items so same set of votes and then
the selection is a process where it's
repeated k times for the number of slots
you have in your front page and you
select the item with the most votes but
then everyone who voted for that their
votes don't count or their boat weight
decreases for a certain period of time
so they have to sit out on the sidelines
and that gives other people a chance to
be heard it so to see how that could
work out with a set of documents we've
got our set of voters you've got four
blue voters and to read voters and a set
of documents that sort of represent blue
and red viewpoints and their voting is
incredibly correlated with those
viewpoints if you run approval voting on
a set of documents and votes you end up
with the set that is entirely blue even
though your population and your votes
were not entirely blue if you run
sidelines the first item is the same
right no one's been sidelined yet you're
on the second and those original voters
for it have to sit out so you end up
with another set of items and then those
voters for the last one this is just
with the one turn sort of trivial
example you then get another blue item
those votes or sit out and you get
another red item ok so here you get a
more balanced set in reality voting is a
bit more sparse in most cases so you
don't quite get this total nay right so
now this is also unproportional to the
actual number vote or to the actual
voters but you do get a more diverse set
all right so how would you measure f
scott lever it deals a little bit
similar to Instant Runoff voting that
fair uh not an implementation but in
spirit and spirited to get a boat you
can vote for your favorite wingnut and
not worry about it because
it won't be kind of against you unless
they're unless their boat rides where
your boat has been wasted here it's not
right so it's quite different because
you have the approval voting where you
get to vote for as many things as you
want you don't have to rank or things
like that it is great but inspiring we
actually pulled some of the ideas for
this from the Chamberlain current method
for selecting committee members that was
actually done for academia where was the
same idea if you want a representative
set of committee members and the ideal
committee is sort of proportional to the
views that it represents but yeah so
similar in spirit to a lot of the voting
work right and then we wanted to measure
how well you're doing if you have one of
these systems right so we came up with
measures of inclusion and exclusion that
sort of got this idea of representing
people alienation and then
proportionality inclusion and exclusion
is the most straightforward of these
it's just the number who had something
they voted for represented exclusion is
the number or the proportion who didn't
billion ation is a little bit more about
how far down the list you went so the
intuition here is that if you have to
read pretty far down the list before you
see something that represents you or
that you agree with you're probably less
happy right and so it's the minimum
position in the list for an agreeable
item and otherwise it's sort of the
length of the list +1 alright so it's
sort of a trivial measure but it gets at
this idea that the further you have to
read the more dissatisfied you're
becoming and so for the results that you
sort of take the position for everyone
the alienation score for every user and
the items the last is proportional
representation and here the idea is that
you've got voters who may be part of a
particular group so red blue purple or
they may be sort of partially right of
different groups so you may have someone
who's socially liberal and fiscally
conservative for example and so it's
possible to have partial group
membership for a set of users of these
right you can sort of come up with the
average memberships for eat in groups of
free each user you can then by looking
at what they voted for come up with sort
of what a document or who a document
represents so you've got voters for an
item it represents for the average group
membership of
those voters and then for a set of items
k you take the average membership or the
average positions of the actual items
that was based on those voters it so now
for the set of items on your front page
you have the positions that it should
represent and then you can compare that
set of users so everyone who voted or
the people you're trying to represent
against the representativeness of the
document set k using just KL divergence
right so it's comparing the two vectors
and so you've got your set of voters if
you have a document set that very very
closely matches it you have a small KL
divergence as your document set gets
further and further from the proportions
of viewpoints in your set of voters you
get a higher KL divergence so lower
divergence is more closer to the being
proportionally representative here okay
so then we want to now we had some
measures we had an algorithm and sort of
a strong manner algorithm of approval
voting that we wanted to go out and test
it against we tested on two data sets
the first was the dig world and business
category and this was in autumn 2008 we
had a number area so you can sort of get
the quick counts for news stories digs
and votes there or voters represented in
it we didn't have categorizations for
what group each of those voters rains we
could only run inclusion and alienation
based on the vote data here sidelines
outperformed your popularity on both
inclusion and on alienation so more
people were included you had to read
less far down the list when I ran
sidelines on that data to come up with
front pages but then we wanted to go and
test this third measure yeah yeah so
threat to there are other stories in
there too that people are voting for and
part of it was the the number of votes
there
I'll follow up with you separately
Island because it's been a while so they
looked at these okay but then we did
want to go back and test the
proportional representation which was do
the sets actually massive proportions of
the views that the voters old so there
we didn't have classification for the
dig users instead we went back and
looked at things that we could classify
and in this case it was a set of 500
political blogs we treated the links
from a blog to a story as a vote which
isn't perfect but it does pretty well
given that people tend to link to things
they agree with and we treated the blogs
as voters and then we classified each of
those blogs using some independent lists
of liberal and conservative blogs as
well as research assistants to judge to
break any ties so we had about fifty two
percent liberal blogs thirty-five
percent conservative and thirteen
percent independent they're linking
patterns were extremely said that the
conservatives tended to link to the same
things in the liberal senator length of
the same things so looking at
proportional representation on a day to
day basis pure popularity did better
though there was super high variation on
days based on what people were voting
for in the stories available for whether
or not either was doing very well but
overall it one on each and in this data
set it also still one for inclusion and
alienation each time so it's doing
better on the metrics but the next
question that comes up is are these
differences noticeable to actual humans
right so we ran a short study with forty
subjects were asked to look at a 12-item
result set that was generated either by
side lines or by pure popularity they
didn't told weren't told that there were
two results us we just ask them if this
was the front page of a news aggregator
how do you do or I'm sorry we have some
of their opinions on each story so
what's the story surprising did it agree
with your opinions and things like that
we had a liberally by a set of users if
we limit it's just those they had an
eighty-nine percent chance of finding
something surprising or something
challenging the sidelines result sets
there's only fifty percent chance with
her popularity so the liberal result or
the slightly liberal set of blogs was
giving us a liberally by a set
I've results sidelines increase the
challenging the chance of finding
something challenging for liberals among
that right so where could this be
applied the first example is right the
news aggregators that we designed it for
and that inspired the question we could
also use it on other voting systems
where diversity matters so for example
Google moderator was used by the Obama
transition team that year to come up
with questions that they wanted the
president to address and for a while
every single question above the fold was
about legalization of marijuana and you
know that certainly tells you one thing
but it does mean that other issues
weren't making it so perhaps head
sidelines been used here it could have
let other issues sort of percolate up to
without changing the order of the first
item I've also wondered if it could work
for places like where you're trying to
figure out what to produce so a site
like threadless where you're basing tee
shirts off of user ratings so maybe you
can map sort of a broader portion of the
market the nice thing about it is you
don't need to know anything about the
content so it just totally independent
of what was actually in the articles for
the classification or for the selection
of items about the user groups or what
they actually are or about long term
voting behavior for this to work so if
preference is shipped you're still fine
yeah yeah it's a voting system that
tries to protect the minorities chance
to be heard but still letting the
majority all right this will get the
first item is a really interesting
assumption which is that book everyone
should be reading a newspaper you could
actually yeah what is newspaper it says
in such a way that I I now at my own
sideline event that says add some
optimal amount of what I like to see in
what I don't like to see and maybe you
would get something that feels a little
bit yeah so this is designed for you a
front page that everyone is seen like
you point out or a market where the same
things are available for everyone if
you're making a threadless example right
so there are times when you're
constrained to that or where it may be
desirable if you're trying to convene a
conversation around a set of items you
can imagine using it for like picking
the books for a book club right
if you don't want to exclude some of the
people who have been participating for a
while this would let the minority people
get some Sun boats for books too all
right so it's sort of one quick pass on
the selection process there's been a lot
of other work including by Daniel Joe
who was one of my colleagues at Michigan
that have been continuing this but my
interest lately has been more in
presentation and understanding people's
preferences so the first of these
studies looks at a simple presentation
example and looking at people's
preferences for diversity so even in the
sideline study people were telling us in
the qualitative responses that they made
a point of visiting websites with
viewpoints different than their own I
would have been happy with this right
this one gave me a different result set
it's good to know diverse opinions but I
can't take too much right or I wouldn't
use a news aggregator be cut but this
one's liberally biased it gives me
things I agree with so I'm good with it
right they didn't want some of it too
much diversity so we had mixed
preferences and when I talked earlier
about selective exposure or challenge
aversion so people who want to happier
with all agreeable items right and the
evidence for that there are competing
theories one of those is that people do
seek out diversity in this context right
so people prefer information that
contains both challenging and supporting
opinions their happiest somewhere in the
middle right with some challenge and
some some agreeable items and there's
some evidence for that particularly from
Usenet groups where Kelly found a lot of
replies from different opinions and also
a self-report studies where people say
that they're using the internet to go
out and seek a few points from both
sides all right so we've got these two
two competing theories and I wanted to
go out and figure out which of these is
right and if people are in fact
challenge averse can we nudge them to
read more diverse news all right
so the overall study design was to show
people with known political biases a
list of links with predicted percentage
of agreeable items so kind of going back
to how I frame the talk of these news
aggregators with some agreeable and some
disagreeable items and then to slightly
vary the presentation of items so if we
have challenged averse people can we
make them happier with more diverse sets
of items than they otherwise would be so
we needed two things to do this we need
people with no one political biases and
we needed a collection of links that had
a predicted amount of agreeable items to
show them so to get the people we turn
to mechanical turk we restricted this to
people in the United States and we asked
them to complete a qualification task so
demographic questions political
affiliation three questions about
political knowledge and then quality
control subjects were randomly asked
these demographic questions it turned
out that some people aged backwards they
were excluded from the study or people
who take even moved right we don't know
if that was careless answering or just
making things up so they were also
excluded we also excluded people who
were not in the in a fairly extreme or
predictable political view so we missed
the murky middle from the study which is
one of his limitations but again we
needed people with fairly robust and
predictable political preferences all
right we ended up with people who are on
average 35 years old 83 men 87 women
from 37 of 50 United States we assign 30
to an article manipulation check where
we asked them if they agreed with in
articles opinions or not and then 30
where they were shown a collection or
sorry 40 where they're showing a
collection of items we asked their
satisfaction with it and is another
manipulation check we assigned 38 to a
condition we asked them the bias of that
collection so we're rebuilding
collections that actually properly
represented the bias we thought they
were we next needed articles so we went
back to our collection of 500 political
blogs and what they were linking to we
took the items that were most linked so
the 40 most link stories from the
previous 24 hours from the conservative
blogs and from the liberal blogs
filtered out tweets youtube videos
Wikipedia articles items that weren't
political so or that didn't match a
predicted bias this was something that
came up in pilot says where people just
didn't want to see this in their news
aggregator
we showed those to those 30 Turkish
asked if they agreed or disagreed each
person or each article was seen by at
least two people if they agreed we kept
it in if they disagreed we had more
people see it and if there was continued
disagreement we included the item
otherwise we left it in okay so at this
point we had our collection of items and
we had our collection of people and
you're ready to go ahead with our
experiment so we had three presentation
conditions between subjects where they
saw either a baseline news that greater
title abstract title abstract an item in
which the or a news aggregator in which
the agreeable items were highlighted so
that we said it think he'll agree with
this it's shaded yellow or highlighted
an order in which we actually moved all
the agreeable items to the top of the
list but they saw the same collection of
items as they as you across the groups
and then we varied the percentage of
agreeable items each time they visit it
and they could visit once a day and look
at the at their collection and rate it
once a day right so for someone it
looked like this they would have a
fairly long abstract a link to the
article the name of its original source
at the bottom we asked them how
satisfied in this condition they were
with the collection and then a bit about
why they responded the way they did all
right so as I mentioned they were asked
either a satisfaction question suppose
this was the front page has satisfied
would you be with the collection of
items or a bias what if any is the
political bias of this collection and
then that random demographics question
check or why the end why they give the
writing they did so what did we find
first to tease apart these two theories
we plotted their responses based on the
percentage of agreeable items and their
satisfaction it looks kinda like a story
for people being challenged averse or
engaging in selective exposure behavior
but there's an awful lot of noise down
here and up there so we wondered if
something else was going on and here we
went back to those open-ended questions
where they asked why they where we asked
why they gave the rating they did a
number of people told us here that they
either wanted more challenge than they
found in the collection or that they
wouldn't want less
challenge so they were very happy that
this was all agreeable opinions sorry a
mix of agreeable and disagreeable
opinions so we coated those people
separately as diversity seeking and had
very high in a greater reliability among
these and this was done independent of
seeing the actual scores they gave who
weren't influenced by that all right so
we take that plot we pull out the
diversity seeking individuals and we
start to see a story that yep they do
indeed appeared to be diversity seeking
they're not happiest at fifty percent
the peaks actually a little closer to
sixty percent agreeable so you still
like to know you're in the majority or
think you are and then the story for the
remaining ones becomes a bit stronger of
a story for those people being
challenged averse if we actually do nmls
model we see significant predictors for
percentage agreement as well as a
percent agreement squared times
diversity seeking so this diversity
seeking people are actually happier and
less happy as you go to an entirely
agreeable set of items and the this
actually ended up explaining just under
half the variance in there sat in their
responses which is pretty high for this
kind of study the satisfaction was a
pretty good driver so for the people we
had we had about 30 subjects who were
challenged a verse in about 10 or
diversity seeking it's a small study of
Mechanical Turk or so I wouldn't read
too much into this as being
representative of the population but
that's who we had the next question was
for those 30 could we notice them to be
happier using our presentation
techniques and those again to recap
where baseline of just the article or
that the title and the abstract
highlighting the agreeable items or
highlighting and placing the agreeable
items first same types of items across
conditions okay and here highlighting
appeared to at least produce stronger
reactions or stronger responses so
people who had no agreeable items were
more unhappy people that all agreeable
items were happier and this may just
bend it made it quicker easier or that
they felt they should so I wouldn't read
too much into it placing the agreeable
items for
interestingly appeared to decrease
satisfaction this was a strange one and
you have a couple ideas for why this
might have happened one is that the
question was at the bottom so there's a
recency effect going on with the
disagreeable items that were also at the
bottom of the list and those were most
salient when they answered the question
the other is that once we started
messing around with order people
actually said oh you are willing to
personalize the set of items so why are
you leaving disagreeable in at all right
so we may have raised their expectations
at that point and then both of those
results are also significant all right
so where do we go from this kind of
result the first is that it sort of
changes the conversation on selective
exposure which until that point I sort
of said well people online are they
either diversity seeking or are they
challenge of verse it turns out that
people at least in the same context we
were both right so some were diversity
seeking some were challenged i vs it
becomes more of a question of under what
contexts do they engage in these
different behaviors and are you know how
do you design for challenge of versus
individuals to nudge them to read more
diverse things the things that we tried
didn't work but the next study which is
still kind of underway so I'm not going
to say a whole lot went back on to this
question of can we nudge behavior in it
in another way so the aim is here were
to do a field evaluation of some
technique or two to nudge people do into
more diverse political news reading and
also to go back and look at whether or
not those preferences that we found in
the previous one challenge a verse verse
diversity seeking or the persuade
ability of people were predicted by
personality traits and in this case we
picked the Big Five personality traits
as well as demographics such as age and
gender the presentation technique we
decided to test this time was a
character on a tightrope so someone who
based on your own reading behavior is
you know they're happy in the middle or
they're gradually at risk of falling off
and this was basis for the idea that a
lot of people at least express agreement
with a norm that they should be reading
diverse news right so if we highlight
when you're disagreeing with it and help
you maybe feel just uncomfortable
with it could we know jute it to read
more diverse news all right and we built
it as a chrome plugin which you can go
ahead and try and it showed your reading
history over time URLs were classified
according to just the domain so we
didn't classify articles again we had
sort of an initial classification of
things at this domain and sometimes we
broke out separate paths like the
conservative columnist on an otherwise
liberal publication we tried to classify
separately when we could it doesn't do
that amazingly on individual articles
but in aggregate it's pretty good we ran
it in a fuel deployment from about
August until well it's still running
though we've stopped the experiment
around November you get feedback where
articles are classified on the domain
with two conditions so one set of people
are randomly assigned to get immediate
feedback of the reading behavior and
ongoing feedback the other condition had
to wait 28 days and said they just see a
countdown number of days remaining until
you actually get your report of how
balanced your how bias you're reading is
we had there before and after browsing
history as well as the survey that they
completed on installation of it with
demographics and personality attributes
as well as their political preferences
we're not totally done with the analysis
yet but what we're finding so far
appears to be small changes in behavior
so we had some folks who after their
initial rates of there before
installation history needed more read
and what really happened is sort of the
the middle stayed about the same or the
median behavior change was zero but
there were some outliers who were way
more persuadable in the treatment group
than in the control group and then there
were groups who were balanced and they
shift these were both smaller groups so
that there weren't that many balanced
people and we had a few conservatives
partly because the primary way we got
subjects was through some publications
that at least our data shows are mostly
read by liberals so science press like
and NPR so it would be nice to have more
there particularly because they had
actually the largest behavior change the
need
group in both cases all right so when we
compare between the control and
treatment we see small effects on the
order of about four new monthly visits
to a far-right site a month or about 20
new monthly visits to a neutral site per
month which is I don't know if that's
enough to actually nudge people's
perceptions so and I do think that we
can do better with better designs in
terms of behavior change but we're
starting to get towards a point where it
may actually be worth measuring how
whether or not people are more aware of
diverse viewpoints whether or not
they're more accepting or tolerant of
other views but I want to try and see if
we can get a bigger effect first so far
our look at personality trait data
hasn't been particularly encouraging
they're not really predictors of reading
behavior or persuade ability so far but
that may change when we get more
subjects in or when we get a better
design so not totally verdicts still out
on that one a little bit all right so so
far I've talked about a set of studies
on political news sites and aggregators
right and that's when people are
actually actively seeking news or
they're coming across of it on sites
that they sort of visit out of habit or
things like that but what about spaces
where diverse exposure may already be
occurring through other means right and
so here I'm looking at non-political
sites and in particular I decided to run
the study on a set of blogs from blogger
com so do people encounter political
discussion there and do they engage with
it and this was motivated by looking at
sort of reviewing that list of concerns
about Mythili in online political
discourse right it stands out the
political bloggers predominantly link to
like-minded bloggers political blog
readers self-segregate high levels of
agreement and common threads on
political blogs challenger version
prevalent and preferences for political
news aggregators but sort of the
recurring theme throughout this is we're
looking at political spaces right spaces
where people go for political
information which strikes me as a lot
like looking for political diversity at
a political rally
it just isn't going to happen right or
if it does it's in some walled off free
speech area right such as reddit /
conservatives things like that it and if
we look at sort of the history of
scholarship and political discourse
people have been celebrating other
spaces for their chances to expose
people to diverse viewpoints so things
like Kiwanis Clubs bowling leagues
bowling alleys restaurants are third
spaces like or the bar right and this
actually the first picture when I
searched on flickr for a creative
commons photo of a bar was actually
people watching the State of the Union
in a bar right like this was fantastic
right okay that doesn't really help but
right so it there's kind of this
recurrent theme that when people come
together for other reasons whether it be
service to their community a hobby or
you know it is the bar down the street
they may be more politically diverse
than they otherwise would be you know
there's still a lot of sorting that
happens at kind of where people choose
to live in things like that but they may
be more diverse than you would certainly
expect to find at a political rally they
listen and frame arguments to protect
those existing relationships so when you
bring up something where you disagree
with others you're kind of in the space
with them and you want them to still
respect you and you listen because you
u-boat with them so you might as well
see what they have to say but the other
you know thing that comes up is that
people often avoid political discussion
or disagreement also as a way to protect
those relationships right so i know that
this antagonizes you so we're not going
to talk about politics at the family
gathering it and the other trend that's
been happening is this increased sort of
segmentation in news right and so people
talk about this inadvertent audience
risk so in nineteen seventy fifty
percent of adults watched one of three
broadcasts of adult americans watched
one of three news broadcasts by 2007 is
to drop to ten percent right and what
else has come in it so we've seen other
news channels we've seen pseudo news
we've seen sports news right we've seen
things like DVR and x 15 so you can
watch something instead of the news
right you have a lot more control of
what you're paying attention to it
anytime when you do turn the media and
then the internet comes along right with
way more choice and way more channel
opportunities so if people can easily
seek out news and filter out the
disagreeable when they seek political
news will people still be exposed to
challenging views in the end right is
there still this inadvertent audience
effect that would happen through these
large news sources that had to cater to
broad audiences like that american norm
is religion and politics don't belong in
the business yeah so I hadn't looked
across culture I've stayed focused on
the American audience for now right
right and so even when I was beginning a
study there were some signs that
politics isn't taboo online right so
discussion of political candidates by
Twitter users eight percent of u.s.
adults were posting political contents
to their social network sites eleven
percent we're discovering for whom their
friends voted for that way people say
they encounter cross-cutting political
discussion online button non-political
spaces so I want to see if we could sort
of quantify the actual discourse in at
least one of those spaces so how
prevalent are political blog posts on
non political blogs what's the
distribution across different categories
of blogs or genres and when readers
encounter it are they like oh I'm going
to stay away from this one or do they
actually engage with it rather than
treating it as taboo so to start down
this road I needed a sample of blogs
which I got by polling blogger coms
recently updated list in January 2008 it
kept only blogs that had at least five
posts were written in English and had
existed for at least about a since
august of the prior year right so long
as it had some same power this had the
nice benefit that I got rid of a lot of
spam blogs as well right and then we
inspect it and eliminated spam blogs and
vlogs are only partially in English so
we further reduced this there were a
tremendous number of spam blogs it and
then we coded the post from those blogs
is political and non-political and
classified blogs by genre and we
eliminated initial spam
impartial english blogs that came up in
the second check and so we had about
just shy of nine thousand blogs and 2.3
million posts from them a little bit
about how we classified post is
political or not we used a really broad
definition so if they mentioned a
political figure or a political topic
and we whether or not it was us or
otherwise we counted it as political
even if it was part of a larger post
that wasn't and this came up new people
would often be talking about their
daughter was sick and here's some
commentary on healthcare policy by the
way right like if only you know
healthcare policy would pass like would
have better access to insurance we
categorized about 6,600 post as
political or not oversampling political
posts and then we use this to train a
multinomial beta Navy base classifier to
classify the remaining posts we'd pretty
good cap on that one this left us with
over 200,000 political posts and over 2
million non political posts from these
blocks the next task was classifying the
blog's into genres so we chose seven
categories from previous literature
diary vlogs hobby and fan professional
and sales politics religion civic and
issue health and wellness and ethnic or
cultural we submitted those blogs to
mechanical turk and ask people to
categorize them we used at least five
categorizations / blog and use to get
another label tool to come up with the
final classification and we checked a
sample of those against ratings from the
research team interview of a reliability
suffered a little bit here a lot of logs
were sort of in between categories so a
diary vlog from someone who had a really
strong hobby of knitting right what what
do you classify it as it just broke down
a little right we also coated comments
according to questions that's right so
these this getting at the question of
engagement so did they in fact have some
political comment did they have other
non political topics where they spam
when people commented they engage with
the political content did they agree or
not when they engaged and then did they
actually say hey this is taboo don't
talk about this here it's a little weird
to do that on a blog since presumably
it's the author's blog but
we're still curious if it happened we
looked at 56 comments from 42 posts for
that one for that was very cross coded
right right so what did we learn first
overall prevalence so a huge number of
vlogs don't talk about politics very
much right but they're you know rate and
that's not surprising right an awful lot
of diary and other blogs out there but
even if you don't talk about politics
that much you have an awful lot of those
blogs and it adds up so about twenty
five percent of political blog posts
come from blogs to talk about politics
less than twenty percent of the time
right and so the actual political
content is spread all over here in terms
of where at what types of blogs is
coming up on when we look at it on over
time we find that the these are spikes
in these on political blogs of when
politics comes up that's highly
correlated with major events so two
thousand six elections execution of
Saddam Hussein 2007 elections and then
sort of a steady uptick throughout the
presidential primaries and caucuses
alright and so according to the actual
categories how did they break out diary
blogs right there were an awful lot of
diary blogs with an awful lot of
comments we also had only 422 political
blogs in the sample alright so about a
tenth of the lesson attempt the number
of diary blogs that we had and for each
of these genres how often did they talk
about politics not surprisingly
political blogs talked about politics
the most the some of them had some
trouble staying on topic next up with
Civic and issue so things like people
worried about climate change that would
often delve into policy issues sometimes
they would just strictly talk about
science posts religion does mix on what
with politics
and then at the tail end where these I
reblogged right where there were some
outliers so people who had Diaries who
had very strong political opinions but
you know most we're not talking about
politics that often but it still adds up
quite a bit and then among these on
political blogs when people did talk
about or post about politics how did
people engage so uh non political blogs
with political posts they got at least
as many comments as the political posts
on those blogs they have at least as
many or slightly more commenters than
the non-political post on the same blog
so it's not like two people getting into
a back-and-forth flame war and they have
slightly higher amount of anonymous
comments which is interesting so people
may be engaging but choosing not to sign
in when they argue with their friend so
this we're all interesting results to me
all right so people are engaging but
maybe they're choosing to protect the
relationship by saying anonymous
engagement in agreement so eighty-three
percent of those comments did actually
engage the political content it wasn't
like they were going back and saying oh
I'm sorry your daughter is sick they
would actually go and engage the
political content even if it only came
up for a brief part of the post it was
still skewed towards the agreement or
neutral but there was disagreement and a
little bit higher than seeing in the
agreement disagreement ratios on
political blogs all right so sort of
overall takeaways from this one is
there's a lot of political talk
happening on non political blogs it's
not taboo so readers are engaging with
it when they see it and then there's
lots of questions remaining about sort
of actual discourse quality right so how
civil is it how many arguments are being
expressed when people do read the
comments are they learning do they
change their opinions and how does it
stack up against other spaces right so
this is I started to study a long time
ago and then came back to it right at a
point at which blogs were no longer
right the most common social media site
right Facebook and Twitter or bigger now
and I think that the dynamics are
different in those and we're studying
right but one of the major takeaways for
me for this is that
even if people when they go to those
news sites are selectively accessing
agreeable viewpoints at least some
invert and exposure to cross-cutting
views is occurring in these other spaces
right so there still isn't an advert an
audience effect it may just not be on
the sites that were used to or in the
forms that were used to all right so
that's sort of a quick overview of four
sets of studies in this area looking at
ways to select content how do you
present diverse content once you have it
what are people's actual preferences and
how might you design for each of those
and then are there spaces where people
are actually discussing politics in
terms of where I am on this right we've
got three measures that are you know I
think pretty good to use for these
algorithms if you can actually get a
particular proportional representation
requires actually knowing people's views
that's a little harder to use you've got
the sidelines algorithm and actually now
a generalized form of it but we don't
yet know sort of how to optimize your
what data sets it works best on so
that's sort of a next step we tested
some presentation with highlighting
replacing agreeable items first not very
exciting results there right it didn't
work but we did try this balance or
extension which led to at least small
behavior changes so now I'm looking to
build on that and we get larger behavior
changes and eventually go back and test
whether or not this leads to some of the
predicted outcomes in terms of people's
viewpoints how they engage with others
or civic engagement people's preferences
for content diversity right people are
neither inherently challenge diverse nor
diversity seeking there's individual
differences at least this context
there's a lot of need to better
understand it and whether or not
personality attributes or other
characteristics can predict them so you
know sort of we have this user what sort
of content might we serve up for them
and then I'm actually pretty excited by
the results about spaces where people
are actually still posting about
politics and engaging with it rather
than choosing to filter it out totally
on
and because they have those other
relationships to protect this may
actually be one of the better chances
for people to engage in with people who
who disagree with them politically but
who their respect and who they want to
persuade or listen to all right and
there's some inadvertent exposure there
that we can better understand all right
okay so you kind of where it goes better
nudges right better selection better
presentation a better understanding of
this political discussion on political
spaces and really all this comes back to
these questions are right does this
actually lead to the predicted outcomes
in the end right if we have people in
countering political views intentionally
or unintentionally right does it
actually make them better inform
citizens does it happen make better
decisions and I just want to say thanks
to collaborators and funders for this
work and there's more information online
you